jetzt schafft suchst du jemanden mein
freund er wollte mich abholen
also ich hier bin ich sonst war niemand
hier aber vielleicht kommt da ja noch
aber erstmal herzlichen glückwunsch
ja danke hast du dich auch beworben ja
und ich bin schon wahnsinnig aufgeregt
ich bekomme das ergebnis gleich eine
standleitung zu meinen eltern damit ich
ihn sofort bescheid sagen kann wenn das
klappt eine standleitung ja das sagt man
wenn man mit jemanden immer in kontakt
ist ich komme aus brasilien aus
marseille ausgeliehen oder santos aber
du kannst mich gerne giorgione okay ich
war ein sao paulo auf der humboldtschule
das ist eine deutsche schule oder besser
eine zweisprachige schule aber gerade
was die kultur angeht muss ich noch
einiges lernen
das kann ich mir vorstellen dass das
kompliziert ist aber die kultur lernt
man wahrscheinlich erst dann kennen wenn
man in dem land ist aber die sprache
sprichst du schon gut danke es geht so
wie sagt man ich drücke dir ist das dein
freund
nein aber den kenne ich auch
entschuldigung für die crews kommst du
gleich neben dem verlaufen laden nein
hier die erste tür rechts und haben die
ferlacher geschmeckt studierst du auch
als seiner krone stein also alex ich bin
auf jetzt studentin hier ob wir
demnächst kommilitonen sind weißt du
wenn du wieder hier draußen bist aber
ich will drücken die daumen
aber es kann nur einer von uns schaffen
entweder alex oder ich die anderen
plätze sind schon vergeben